hey guys welcome back to brand-new V -
Rebecca apex legends again instead of
you doing something a little bit
different I usually cover the news of
apex legends but we're gonna be going
over actually the lore of the new season
one battle past character Octavio Silva
or also known as octane so to go over
some basic information Octane's real
name is Octavio Silva he's 24 years old
and his home world is Samantha or some
if there's a P in the beginning of this
word I don't actually know how to
pronounce it and I don't remember ever
seeing this within the titanfall
universe of the lore so this is so far a
little bit unknown to us his tactical
booty is called stim passive ability is
swift amend and the ultimate is the
launch pad now going into some titanfall
lore if we piece together some things
the huge conflict that was started this
whole thing was the frontier war which
was the titanfall one story line one of
those biggest battles is the Battle of
Demeter and then five years after that
battle is the storyline of titanfall 2
and apex Legends takes place 30 years
after titanfall 2 so octane was roughly
born around half a decade after the
events of titanfall 2 this means
literally nothing I just wanted to piece
that together but octane is known as the
adrenaline junkie one day Octavia Silva
was bored in fact he was bored most of
his days heir to the preoccupied CEOs of
Silva pharmaceuticals and wanting for
nothing in his life he entertained
himself by performing death-defying
stunts and posting holo vids of them to
his fans to gawk over so this day he
decided to set the course record for the
nearby gauntlet by launching himself
across the finish line
using a grenade as he lays in triage
hours later the doctors informed and
that the damage done to his legs meant
his daredevil days were over but that
didn't sit well with Octavio who turned
to an old friend for help as a chi who
he guilted into forging in order to
replace his legs with biotic ones
suddenly able to repair his limbs at a
moment's notice Octavio decided petty
online stunts weren't enough for him and
the ultimate adrenaline rush for him was
the apex Games I was going to become the
apex champion doing the most incredible
death-defying moves anyone's ever seen
and maybe he won't be so bored in the
arena that was a quick brief history
about octane in the adrenaline junkie
but what I wanted to go over actually is
the parts with AJ Chi and the gauntlet
so the gauntlet is actually from
titanfall - it's the game-mode that you
play in the beginning when you test
yourself to be a pilot and the cool
thing about this is is that the world
record for the gauntlet will show on
screen is 12
and this was completed either a couple
weeks to a month ago and the big strats
using for this with speedrunners is that
you would launch yourself a with a
grenade so octane of course trying to
beat the world record was trying to use
a grenade to cross the finish line and
ended up messing up and blowing off his
legs but like I said he turned to a
person for help dr. ash ahe and I I
don't actually know if I'm pronouncing
this correctly but a J is actually the
name for lifeline so he ended up
actually turning to one of the
characters or one of the champions in
apex legends to actually help him get
his legs back so that's a pretty nice
nod to the other characters within the
storyline and of course if you don't
know who the lifeline is she is the
combat medic of the game so I think her
doing this for octane fits pretty well
with her abilities and how they coincide
together but for his tactical passive
and ultimate we have the stim ability
which means he moves 30% faster for 6
seconds and costs his health to use this
is of course because now that he has
robotic legs and he's always been doing
death-defying stuff he's very good at
running really fast and when he uses the
stim ability he actually puts it in one
of the gas mask holes in his face so it
looks like he's stabbing his cheek so he
can get the faster ability for those six
seconds passive abilities called swift
mend and this automatically restores his
health over time now this could also be
because of the robotics that aj chi or
lifeline gave him so this could possibly
be some type of reason or some backstory
of why he even has this passive ability
and for his ultimate we have the launch
pad and since he loves doing
death-defying stunts of course you have
to pair some type of trampoline or
bungee and that's where the launch pad
comes in where you deploy a jump head
that catapults teammates throughout the
air so this completely fits his
character here's a picture on screen of
exactly what I meant by death-defying
stunts during the gauntlet of course he
was trying to flex a little bit with
everyone out in the stadium and this is
around the time that he blew up the
grenade and he took a little picture
with the selfie stick trying to show off
to everybody that he was gonna beat the
record but either if he didn't cross the
finish line or he did cross the finish
line we all know what happened he ended
up losing all of the mobility in his
legs and had to get robotic ones one
thing I noticed is that actually on his
arm he has this tattoo and I can't
actually see what all of it spells but I
think it might mean something I don't
actually know I don't know everything
about the titanfall universe and of
course this is a pretty vague tattoo I
don't know if it means anything at all
but if it does definite let me know in
the comments below and give me your
thoughts on that
be a guys that's gonna be the quick lure
of octane the new hero if you guys want
me to do lore of the new characters
coming no season 2 season 3 etc and want
me to give you a little bit of a
backstory of these characters and how
they came to be apex champions and let
me know in the comments below and I'll
gladly do that in the future for you
guys but that's gonna be the end of the
vid so you guys hopefully guys did enjoy
if you did let me know by leaving a
comment and liking the video and also
subscribing for more apex legends lore
and news content my two most recent
videos are gonna be popping up on screen
if you guys want to check those out they
have a great rest of your day and peace
out and enjoy a season one
[Music]